president biden speaking for almost a
half an hour while the speech and then
he took several questions including from
our own peter ducey just one quote that
he had from uh the speech and i'll get
everybody's reaction here uh when it
comes to the terrorists who did the
attack today he said we will not forgive
we will not forget we
will haunt you down and make you pay
with all the resources at his command as
the president of the united states um
the other thing that he
peter ducey asked him do you bear any
responsibility for what's happened in
the last two weeks he says i bear
responsibility for fundamentally all
that happened of late but here's the
deal and here's the but you know i wish
one day you would say these things you
know as well as i do that the former
president meaning president trump made a
deal with the taliban he also uh paid
tribute to the 12 u.s service members
who died today in this terrorist attack
and he asked the nation for a moment of
silence so um this was the speech that
he gave uh bill hemmer i want to give
your thoughts as you well a couple
things here i'll go quickly to make sure
everybody gets a chance here um i
thought peter got as close to the
essential question as anyone did and
that is sir is this on you and in so
many ways we heard that question from
peter with regard to the um the future
here i thought he had a few strong
moments uh i would argue also that all
these moments were late by about 10 days
i i don't know if he's going to say
these isis terrorists will not win and
we'll hunt them down and we will not
forgive and forget i think that is all
that is the proper language but how you
do that from over the horizon how you do
that when you're when you're leaving how
you do that when it's pretty clear from
the comments right there that we're
still gone as of tuesday the 31st of
august with regard to the peace treaty
here it is
i mean and a remarkable twist of irony
it's six pages in length it was signed
on february 29 2020
which was a saturday
leap day in a leap year you know what
also happened that day
south carolina primary which catapulted
joe biden to the head of the democratic
primary in this agreement it states
there are four parts to it and one of
them mentioned four different times is
intra-afghan negotiations between both
sides the afghan government and the
taliban for whatever reason blame
whomever you want to blame that did not
happen according to this deal jesse
he doesn't have to go by the trump
afghan deal he's shredded so many trump
deals remain in mexico pipelines all of
a sudden he has to do what trump did i'm
not buying that at all the headline here
is that he's sticking to the deadline
the other headline is he's going to do
whatever it takes to kill these suckers
that blasted us today and rescue every
american that's still stranded
in general the vibe was off labored
breathing
array of emotions at one point he
started crying the next time he was like
john wayne getting tough
i couldn't tell what was going on he'd
actually said that it was not a mistake
to put the taliban in charge of being
our bodyguards not a mistake wouldn't do
it any other way right then he went out
of his way to do two things defensively
in my opinion
he explicitly said how engaged he was
how many times he was briefed
he knows the perception is he's
disengaged number two
the commanders all agree everyone's in
agreement there's no disagreement i'm
not buying that for a minute i believe
there's a ton of disagreement especially
when it comes to retaking bagram he put
that on the generals and they said oh no
generals don't want to retake bagram
yeah because you have five days left to
hit the deadline and you only have 5 000
troops
all in all
he said a couple good things off of a
teleprompter but i'm not convinced he
means them because he's totally shredded
his credibility by being wrong
and not being tough enough i say
something about bagram just to follow up
real quickly and then i'll get to greg
um bagram we left on july 6 2021 that
was the same week that joe biden was
saying the taliban had a very low chance
of taking over the country so it's a
very different thing for him to say now
that we don't want to reopen bagram at
the time the general said it wasn't a
military asset for us and we also
weren't planning this mass evacuation
and this airlift which they keep touting
as some kind of success the biggest
airlift in history why are we doing an
airlift i mean right so the timeline on
that is dishonest they really very much
want credit for the airlift you hear
that even from reporters have covered
the white house for a long time like
okay yeah we get it you want the credit
for the airlift and we want people to
get out he said greg that he's going to
get everybody out i don't they didn't
talk about resources yeah i don't know
how you can fight while you're running
away
bill already said that how do you hunt
and withdraw at the same time uh you
know who instructed him
who instructed him to pick the reporters
when he said i've been instructed was
that also the taliban are they also in
charge of the presser
just call on them you know yeah just
call on him i've been instructed because
you immediately when he says that you
you
you put it in with the fact that he
looks incredibly defeated he just fee
it's like you you're not you don't have
this feel of confidence maybe it was
just because he was sad but he said he
he sounded defeated he sounded tired uh
there wasn't there was a flash of anger
here and there and the other thing that
uh i i've never
i never trust anybody that says
consensus
any time that you ask something about
somebody and they go well there was a
consensus that means it was a bad idea
because you don't get good ideas by
consensus no you don't you get the worst
idea by consensus because everybody is
looking out for each other and they and
they all blend and that's what happened
katie um the entity that is not defeated
or tired is the taliban and isis gay
well and you know joe biden wants to
talk about how the taliban is acting in
our interests but it's the taliban who
let isis and al-qaeda out of that prison
so eliminating any kind of
responsibility from the taliban in the
situation i don't think it's going to
fly when it comes to the facts let's say
one last thing dana i think every flag
around this country immediately and
every capital around the world should be
lowered in memory of those marines we
lost today they gave their lives for the
ultimate sacrifice and that was to try
and help an aspect of humanity that
needed it dearly and right now there are
thousands and thousands of people back
in afghanistan as we speak who still
need the help god bless them and they
will um
they'll continue to out to carry out
this mission um and as
trey yanks was saying they have to
retrograde which means basically you
have to figure out a way to get all of
your troops out uh on time hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else